when we're dealing with population
growth rates an interesting question is
how long would it take for a given rate
for the population to
double so we're going to think about
doubling time
now if you were to actually calculate it
precisely mathematically precisely it
gets a little bit mathy you need to use
a little bit of logarithms and you'll
probably need a calculator but i did
that here in the spreadsheet by
calculating the exact doubling time so
this is saying that if a population is
growing at one percent a year it's going
to take almost 70 years for that
population to double but if that
population is growing at 5
per year then it's going to take a
little over 14 years for that population
to double
if the population is growing at 10
percent
we know mathematically it's going to
take a little bit over seven years for
that population to double
now i was able to calculate this as i
just mentioned using a little bit of
fancy math but what we see in this next
column is there's actually a pretty easy
way to approximate doubling time and
this is known as the rule of 70 and the
rule of 70 is used in a lot of different
areas a lot of different subjects people
in finance would use it because once
again you're thinking about things
growing at a certain percent every year
but you can also use it for things like
population growth rates so what we see
with the rule of 70 and let me just
write that down
rule
of 70 is that you can approximate the
doubling time by taking the number of 70
and dividing it by the not actually the
percentage but just the number of the
percentage so for example
this right over here is 70
divided by
this one here
which is equal to 70.
and notice this 70 is pretty close to
69.7
if you wanted to figure out or you
wanted to approximate the doubling time
if the population is growing at 7 a year
well what you would say is all right
what is 70 divided by
7 well that is equal to 10. so this
would be your approximation and if you
were doing it in a mathematically
precise way it would be 10.2
so if you're taking say an ap
environmental science course and they're
asking you for the how long it takes for
something to double let's say a
population is growing seven percent a
year they're probably expecting you to
use the rule of 70.
so let's say that we have a population
that is growing
at
14
per year and that would actually be a
very huge growth rate
what i want you to do is pause this
video and approximate how long would it
take for that population to double
all right now let's work through this
together so as i mentioned we're
approximating we're not we don't have to
do the calculate the exact doubling time
so for approximating it it's going to be
70 divided by
the rate of growth so in this situation
this is going to be 70 divided by 14
which is equal to 5. so if a population
is going at 14 it'll take it roughly 5
years to double